et on en parle du coronavirus avec
gérald cars ex médecin urgentiste à
l'hôpital lieu de paris mérigeau le tas
dieu merci d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau on l'a vu un visite d' emmanuel
macron à l'hôpital
ça peut être fière de paris l'elysée a
dit que c'était une visite qui était
censé à rassurer les français est ce que
c'est le cas c'est une opération
effectivement pour assurer de
communication on les voit se balader
dans le service
y'a pas de masque par exemple il insiste
sur le fait que ça ne sert à rien et qui
a pas de risque donc ça ne sert à rien
de mettre un masque et il a raison c'est
une opération de pédagogie aussi et
c'est vrai que c'est important parce que
les gens sont inquiets moi j'étais un
début de semaine de garde les gens dans
la salle d'attenté étaient tous avec en
masquant ainsi je viens à l'hôpital je
risque d'attraper quelque chose et donc
là le fait que le président avec le
ministre et le directeur général de la
santé visites les services son masque ça
veut dire le message subliminal c'est
vous pouvez venir à l'hôpital
il faut que les gens viennent à
l'hôpital quand ils ont un rendez-vous
continent une intervention chirurgicale
il ne risque pas d'être contaminés ça
c'est le premier ses premiers effets
positifs de ce type de visite
alors on l'a vu à emmanuel macron
interpellé par ce médecin on vient de le
voir un médecin très en colère l'hôpital
public est en crise est ce que le
gouvernement la conscience aujourd'hui
alors c'est pas une colère le collègue
françois sacha la sq est neurologue a
pitié salpêtrière qui monte du collectif
un terreau pitot que c'est ce collectif
qui crient depuis dessins de 20 ans qui
démissionnent leur poste de chef de
service etc et on a l'impression c'est
ce qu'il a dit qu' il ya une phase de
diagnostic quand la agnès buzyn la
ministre de la santé de l'époque parce
qu'elle a été
elle est partie sur d'autres sur
d'autres voies mais elle a écouté a fait
le diagnostic et puis après on a attendu
on a attendu beaucoup et ça fait deux
ans et demi que la situation s'aggrave
présent maquereau a raison de dire la
situation était déjà grave sauf qu'elle
s'aggrave encore l empire depuis deux
ans et demi avec l'impression nous on a
un gouvernement en face de nous qui est
sourd aux revendications et là quand le
collègue dit on est au bout et on n'est
pas loin du pire série c'est la goutte
d'eau qui ferait déborder le vase et le
corona virus il faudrait pas que ce soit
la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le
vase
je vous prends juste un exemple très
concret si on arrive en phase épidémique
et si on a besoin de place de
réanimation parce que des malades
atteints du coronavirus ont besoin de
réanimation et on le sait par rapport à
l'expérience chinoise
il ya une phase très critique pendant
quatre cinq six jours où les malades ont
besoin parce qu'ils ont les poumons
atteints par le virus d'une pneumonie
on a besoin de ventiler les malades avec
des respirateurs artificiels ça c'est la
réanimation
on est actuellement permanence en flux
tendu énormément de service de
réanimation en province à paris ont
fermé ont été restructurés se sont
regroupés bref on est en flux tendu en
permanence imaginez qu'on ait besoin
ne serait ce que d'une dizaine de lits
de réanimation pour des malades par
exemple dans un département comme le
rhône on est incapable d'accueillir que
ça veut dire que vous n'êtes que la
france les hôpitaux français aujourd'hui
ne sont pas prêts à accueillir
l'épidémie du salon derrière les
hôpitaux français sont prêts tant qu'on
est à cette phase comme ça de deux cas
groupés etc
si vraiment on a une phase épidémique
avec des complications et je suis loin
d'affoler les gens au contraire je pense
que le coronavirus c'est plutôt quelque
chose qui s'assimile à un virus très
contagieux mais peu virulent mais peu
virulent ça veut dire quand même qu'il y
aura des gens avec des complications et
des gens avec des complications de la
grippe qui fait dix mille morts par an
chacun par an ces dix mille morts en
france probablement parmi ces dix mille
morts il ya des gens qui sont morts
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas de place de
réanimation imaginer qu'on rajoute avec
le coronavirus des gens qui auraient
besoin de lits de réanimation vu la
médiatisation la politisation du dossier
je pense qu'on pourra pas accepter cinq
à dix mille morts qui est la mortalité
normal virus respiratoires mais
cinq à dix mille morts sur le
coronavirus ça serait inacceptable dans
l'ambiance
l'ambiance générale est ce que 10 de ce
collègue à la pitié c'est que on n'est
pas capable de gérer ses places de
réanimation ses besoins si la crise
prend de l'ampleur
et ça ça va pas se décréter comme ça
d'un coup de cuillère à pot d'un
claquement de doigts c'est à dire que la
situation qu'on dénonce depuis des mois
voire des années présent à parler de
moins d'hypocrisie moins d'hypocrisie
pour les politiques qui crient au
scandale aujourd'hui alors qu'eux mêmes
ont cautionné ont fermé les lignes à
quelques années bah ça ça va pas il va
falloir rhabiller l'hôpital il va
falloir réarmer l'hôpital et ça ça va
pas se faire un jour à l'autre alors sur
le coronavirus les français ont un peu
de mal à se positionner certains sont
paranoïaques à une peur irrationnelle
qui est en train de jour d'hui de mûrir
sur le territoire français est ce qu'on
doit avoir peur du coronavirus
aujourd'hui il ya une peur je passe il
est rationnel ou irrationnelle quand on
a peur c'est parfois irrationnel mais en
tout cas nous on a peur et pour nous
c'est bien rationnelle donc les gens
sont inquiets et c'est normal parce
qu'on a vu et on entendu plein de choses
sur ce mystérieux virus chinois il ya
quelques semaines il est pas mystérieux
on le connaît on est capable de
l'identifier on a des tests il ya des
vaccins qui sont même en cours
certaines équipes qui travaillent sur
des vaccins et puis surtout on a
l'expérience chinoise qui nous montre
quoi qui nous montre que l'immense
majorité quand je dis l'immense majorité
c'est 98 % des malades atteints par le
coronavirus guérissent iris soit
spontanément pour 80% d'entre eux soit
pour une partie de la population parce
que fragiliser parce que âgées il ya
besoin de services de réanimation pour
pouvoir apporter de l'oxygène pour
pouvoir passer un cap un peu et guy un
cap critique et puis malheureusement
pour une petite partie de la population
alors on dit 2% moi je pense qu'on est
largement en dessous en termes de
mortalité parce qu'on sait pas le nombre
de personnes réelles qui sont contaminés
dans c'est très difficile de calculer un
taux de mortalité mais pour une infime
partie qui est souvent fragilisés il ya
effectivement des complications
gravissime qui peuvent aboutir jusqu'au
début jusqu'au décès et voyez on est 98
99 % de guérison et le cas du patient
venu de creil qui restait à creil
pendant six jours qui est décédé à la
pitié salpêtrière
on sait pas par qui il a été contaminé
ce qui prouve que
on peut avoir le corona virus et ne pas
avoir de symptômes ou ne pas s'en rendre
compte et probablement que la personne
qui l'a contaminée
ben elle entendra jamais parlé du
couronne à virus peut être qu'on ne la
retrouvera jamais et tant mieux à la
limite puisque ça veut dire qu'elle
guérit spontanément justement une
enquête est en cours pour déterminer
comment il aurait pu contracter le virus
alors l'om est-ce évoque un risque de
pandémie emmanuel maps on parle lui
d'une épidémie on en est où actuellement
alors là aussi le mot fait peur c'est un
pandémie on a l'impression que c'est un
truc horrible
chaque année il ya une pandémie dans le
monde pandémie ça veut dire une épidémie
qui se répand sur tous les continents au
moins deux continents c'est bien ça pour
la moelle et au continent mais
globalement c'est quand il ya beaucoup
de cas dans des continents et
globalement c'est le monde entier et la
pandémie si la pandémie grippale
chaque année on a une grippe qui part
d'asie qui se déplacent qui arrive en
europe qui atteint les états unis
l'amérique du sud
c'est une pandémie donc l'humour lui
même ne doit pas faire peur c'est juste
une définition épidémiologique qui dit
qui est une épidémie partout dans le
monde et le présent macron a dit on est
devant une épidémie oui probablement et
s'il dit ça c'est que il écoute aussi
les infectiologues qui lui disent le
virus y circulent déjà
le fait qu'on ait deux passions dont on
ne connaissent pas le mode de
contamination
ça veut dire qu'il ya déjà du virus qui
est circulant en france et qu'on est
alors n'est pas encore sur une phase
d'épidémie parce qu'il faut un grand
nombre de malades pour pouvoir parler
d'épidémie on est encore sur des foyers
qui sont localisés et donc on est encore
il serait encore pis il est encore temps
de circonscrire un peu ces foyers là
pour ça ne devienne pas une épidémie
enfin globalement ça paraît
difficilement évitable et si on a une
épidémie ça sera comme une épidémie
grippe
après c'est à la réserve que le virus ne
mute pas etc
mais encore une fois l'expérience
chinoise nous montre que les craintes
initiales ne sont pas forcément fondée
que cette expérience là et on a
maintenant un petit peu de recul et on
voit qu'en chine l'ailé depuis 23 jours
à l'esj les chiffres sont en train de
diminuer ya plus de cas en dehors de
chine que de grands chine et ça c'est
plutôt rassurant
gérald cardiaque merci d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
urgentiste à l'hôtel dieu de paris merci